(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(upbeat orchestral music)
- [Narrator] In the Besòs
neighborhood of Barcelona,
there is a unique group of girls.
(girls chattering)
The country's first, and only,
all-female cricket team.
And this team is made up
entirely of immigrants.
(speaking in foreign language)
(crowd cheering)
(tapping)
(upbeat guitar music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(crowd cheering)
(crowd applauding)
(speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
The team has allowed the
girls to form a community
of their own, while at the same time,
helping to overcome the challenges
of immigrating to a new country.
(speaking in foreign language)
(crowd cheering)